there's only a difference between okay
well what is goodness what is truth and
then we can have a conversation about
that and we'll be happy to show that
Islam is the truth and we can have that
conversation yeah so so you have that
cleared up there that jihad does not
equal holy war I believe that this is
actually a Christian term holy war this
is not the Crusades the Crusades that's
number one so jihad to struggle and
strive then you have also what you had
talked about in this aspect where you
had for instance if you study history
you had Spain for instance you had two
fractions of Christians fighting each
other and one is oppressing the other
and then you have these Christians who
are opening the doors calling the
Muslims to come in to help could we who
can use this as one example right of a
jihad so then they came in but they
didn't come in now massacring everyone
like like you had Kim what would the
Spanish Inquisition is where they were
just just everybody by the sword convert
or die you had once they were in you had
Islam because of his men I mean
obviously they came in there was some
fighting but at the end you know people
were being oppressed
now Islam comes in just as a slab
established and you can't have peace
without the justice and now people were
freely accepting the Muslims do we it's
hard to imagine because there are so
many connotations and stereotypes yeah
about what does it mean to have like a
conquest yeah
right but and though you say an opening
where they opened up they open and it's
basically new management
nothing it's new management but it
doesn't mean you know we're going to go
door to door like this is Nazi Germany
yeah we're going to put you in camps
like that people in the prior to the
nation-state and the modern period you
have nation-states but prior to that you
had governorships and people were used
to these changes in management right
it's just a difference of who you're
paying your taxes to and then there are
certain restrictions that will apply
depending on who's in charge but that
was something that was normal and
accepted but the thing is that when you
have the opening of Egypt or you have
opening of Persia or North Africa or
Spain it wasn't this bloody massacre
it's from the true perspective the
spreading of truth and then within those
lands the people would convert after
seeing the benefits that Islam is
bringing to their land okay we've just
been conquered this is what happened in
Persia okay we've just been conquered by
these Arabs and we have a natural
aversion because of racism to Arabs this
is the Persian Empire but then after a
generation or two we see Wow
Islam is is has prohibited fornication
Islam has prohibited adultery Islam has
prohibited incest which was a big
practice with the Zoroastrians prior to
Islam Islam is bringing peace Islam is
bringing family cohesion Aslam is
bringing a strong community that is
oriented toward God towards loving and
worshiping God we're experiencing all of
these benefits in terms of our material
in terms of our character in terms of
justice Islam comes and prohibits Ussuri
interest right something that is such an
evil social evil that oppresses Islam is
coming and abolishing it you know the
Quran is abolishing it so then this wow
this is the truth like this compared
what we have now under new management
with what we had before okay then this
is how being taught that entire region
became Muslim and some of the greatest
scholars of Islam so in the Islam were
coming from Iran from Persia and so
that's something that I can see a part
of my heritage but this happened all
across the Middle East North Africa and
there's nothing that as Muslims we
should be ashamed of that in fact we
have to be proud of that history and
that heritage yeah moving on to the next
but just reiterating this point like
that many people those that know but for
those that don't know you had those
clear guidelines even when the opening
offensive or whatever battles were
taking place before the Geneva
Convention
you had the example of the Prophet SAW
some who was sent as a mercy to mankind
where there was a clear if you're gonna
engage in battlefield in battle the
restrictions again killing innocent
women children monks in their places of
worship or harming people who are who
are not engaged in the battles these
kind of things this was unknown at that
time I mean there was because people
think like Mongols coming in everybody's
dying pregnant woman every brave and all
that this is something that an
antithesis of Islam to see those rules
of engagement so clearly laid out even
before the Geneva Convention right it's
something that is contrary to Islamic
principles as you mentioned to just go
and massacre it's also contrary to the
ID philosophy of Islam at a very deep
level let me explain why because so many
of the conflicts in history the vast
majority are on the basis of ethnic
conflict right
you had the Mongols who invaded and they
were an ethnicity and they were
massacring uh you know non Mongols right
you have Han Chinese you have different
African tribes all of this ethnic
conflict in Europe the history of all of
the wars many of the wars were based on
the basis of ethnicity more than
religion but Islam is not an ethnicity
Islam is a Deen right it's a religion
and people can convert to their religion
and so actually from a material point of
view even if you take out a conception
of God and religion out of it even from
a purely materialistic standpoint it
would be a contrary to the logic of
Muslims to kill non-muslims why because
you want them to convert eventually and
then they're part of your army they're
part of your empire and so your empire
is growing right and you're getting that
kind of growth in numbers which is so
important in pre-modern times because
whoever has the biggest army is going to
win right it's now win the battle and
and mostly it's a numbers game so you
want as many
people as possible to become Muslim it
doesn't matter if you're black white
whatever race right whatever ethnicity
you're coming in so it's contrary to the
flock but if you have an ethnic based
philosophy that we have a certain race
white black Asian whatever then no we
have to kill the non-whites because they
might start reproducing and then there
are armies that if we like beat them
once and we don't Massacre them all then
they're going to start having kids
they're gonna have babies then their
armies grow your ethnicity is gonna grow
and then they're gonna take their
revenge
yeah so from an ethnic basis we know we
have to Massacre as many as we can
yeah and this is what you so we have to
rape as many as we can this is what
you've seen in the in the greatest
genocide after World War Two in Bosnia
where my family's from this is what was
happening nationalistic wars things like
this yeah this is the Serbs yeah yes all
right